[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN BROOKS: All right,
thanks for joining, everyone.
Welcome to OPS211, Continuous
Integration and Delivery
into Kubernetes.
My name is Justin Brooks.
I'm the director of
engineering at SADA Systems.
Just some background,
I've been working there
about eight years.
I've been the director
of engineering for four.
SADA is a reseller for
Google Cloud Platform.
We help customers
onboard onto GCP
or transform their
existing GCP applications
into more optimal
implementations.
In this presentation,
I'll be going over
a little bit about Kubernetes,
a little bit about CI/CD,
and our best practice
recommendations
for what we implemented
for one of our applications
for one of our
products called Atom.
So what is continuous
integration?
You guys probably already
have a brief understanding
of what that is.
But just to rehash it, it
involves developers integrating
code as often as possible
within a shared repository
and the process around that,
including automating, building,
and testing for
that application.
It allows teams to get feedback
quickly and find issues early.
And then it can be
extended further
after you've implemented CI
into either something called
continuous delivery or
continuous deployment,
where those changes
are automatically
deployed into various
environment levels.
So on the screen here now,
we have a sample application
infrastructure on
what something could
look like that
incorporates Kubernetes.
You'll notice that the
important components here
are the implementation
of the Container
Registry for hosting
Docker images and GitHub
for your source control.
So briefly about
Kubernetes, at a glance
this is sort of
the representation
of the architecture
of Kubernetes.
It helps you manage
container clusters,
supports multi-cloud,
bare metal environments,
and supports multiple
container runtimes.
There are several also
additional benefits
you get out of running
GKE on Google Cloud,
including auto-scaling
and auto-healing.
One of the components of
Kubernetes is the API server.
So this is basically how you
do all of your interactions
with the Kubernetes
cluster and is essentially
how the CI tool is going to
interface with the cluster
as well.
It's all API-centric.
There's no private APIs.
There's no system-only call.
Everything communicates
through the API.
And it's a RESTful
type of service.
So you see, we have an example
of that you can actually
see on the bottom
right hand side,
although you can't
really read it.
The detailed logs that
you get in Stackdriver
are showing all the API
calls that are being
made as part of a deployment.
Controllers are fundamental
to how Kubernetes work.
It's a piece of code that
watches a Kubernetes API
and reacts accordingly.
Essentially, it's code
that runs in a loop,
listens to the API server,
and responds to changes.
For example, when
you want to create
a pod, what you really want
is to schedule something
in the system.
The scheduler wakes
up in the system,
determines where it's
going to put in the pod,
and it writes back
to the API server.
The kubelet then wakes
up and orchestrates
what we want to the system.
So it's all unified together
as part of this process that's
part of the CI/CD pipeline.
So the nodes, the nodes are
the actual worker machines that
run the containers, manage
the master components,
including services like the
container runtime, the kubelet,
and the kube-proxy.
If you're running it
in on-prem environment,
this would be a
physical machine.
If you're running in the
cloud, it's most likely
going to be a virtual machine.
The container runtime
has a interface
which actually
facilitates pluggability,
supporting different types
of containers, including
Docker, rkt, and others.
The kubelet is the most
prominent controller
which implements the
pod and the node APIs
to drive the container
execution layer.
And the kube-proxy is
a service abstraction
that groups pods under
a common access policy.
It programs the IP table
rules to trap access
to service virtual
IPs and redirect them
to the appropriate backup.
The pods are small groups
of containers and volumes.
They're tightly coupled.
They live and die together, as
they're spun up and spun down.
And they have shared
networking and lifecycle.
The containers within a
pod share an IP address,
and they find each
other via localhost.
Now, a pod typically is set up
to run just a single container.
But it can run
multiple if necessary,
depending on the use case.
Deployments are the declarative
updates for the pod.
So basically, you
specify a desired state.
The deployment controller then
handles the actual execution
of reaching that state.
Services are an
abstraction that defines
the logical set of
pods and the policy
by which they are accessed.
Each pod has an IP.
Services provide a
stable virtual IP,
so that even as you
scale up and down as part
of your process for
auto-scaling or any issues
with self-healing, it
maintains a single virtual IP
that you can use to
access those services.
And finally, secrets
and ConfigMaps,
these hold all the sensitive
information, such as passwords,
OAuth tokens, et cetera.
This is obviously going
to be a key component
of the CI/CD process for
maintaining the secrets that
are going to be distributed
across each environment.
There are numerous
automatic secrets
that are created by Kubernetes
to store the credentials
to access the API.
They are base64
encoded, not encrypted.
The ConfigMaps are
then used to store
the nonsensitive information.
And then you have
an imagePullSecrets
that's utilized to set
Container Registry credentials.
That's going to
be crucial when we
talk about the implementation
of the CI/CD pipeline
and how it interfaces.
Kubectl is obviously
the main CLI
that you're going to utilize
to execute any actions
against the cluster--
listing pods, applying
changes, things of that nature.
This is another key
component that's
going to be utilized
by our CI tool
as part of the build and
for the CI/CD component
for the deployment.
So now, we get into
orchestration tools.
These are key components
of the CI/CD process
that are utilized in the
actual automation pipeline.
So GCP service accounts
are going to be crucial.
Everything should be running
through a service account,
rather than a user account.
You'll be managing those
directly, typically
either within some form of a
deployment management solution
or in the console or
even via the gcloud CLI.
Deployment Manager is a
solution that's typically
used Google native around
automating the cloud
deployment, so that you have
your infrastructure codified.
It's repeatable, declarative.
The templates can also be
pulled once created manually
for resource recreation.
So you can reuse that across
multiple different services.
Now, Terraform is often a
common alternative to this.
That's also useful.
They both have their drawbacks.
In this particular
instance, we're
talking about a GCP Deployment
Manager implementation.
For automation, we are
utilizing Travis CI.
It's basically a hosted
CI tool for handling
all of the automation.
All of our scripts are in there.
So it handles everything from
downloading the gcloud SDK;
setting the appropriate
zone, cluster, and project
to deploy to; activating
a service account;
and installing the kubectl CLI.
Obviously, CircleCI is another
alternative, Cloud Build,
Jenkins, any tool.
We actually use a combination
of both Travis and Circle
in our implementation.
For our artifact repository,
we're utilizing Artifactory.
It's a universal
artifact repository.
It's been around for
a while, supports
many software packages
created in any language,
CI/CD integration with
nearly every provider,
and Hook Properties
for simple querying
when you need to
access specific items.
It handles all of these
different multiple repository
types, including Docker,
NPM, Maven, Gradle,
Debian, and generic repository.
So those listed out are key,
because those are actually
the big components as part
of our Kubernetes CI/CD
deployment.
The generic artifact
repository, in this case,
is utilized for the Android APK.
That allows us to build and test
and publish internally prior
to leasing to the App Store.
Also note, in this
implementation
we discuss potentially
utilizing Helm.
In our implementation,
we do not yet use that,
but it is a recommended
use case and would
be useful in the future to
be hosted in Artifactory.
So the build pipeline.
This is where we talk
about essentially
how it's all orchestrated.
In our particular
build pipeline,
the application
code is decoupled
from the infrastructure code
in separate repositories.
So we have two different
repositories for each service
that we're deploying.
The deployments are orchestrated
on these various environments.
Or specific
containers are, again,
completely disassociated
from the application code.
So the process at a
really high level--
and we'll walk through
that deeper later--
is that the application code is
built, compiled, and packaged.
Code is pushed to the
binary repository, which
houses binaries of all
sorts, including the NPM
modules, any jars, Docker
images, and any other binaries
that might be needed.
And then upon
deployment, the binary
is pulled from the repository
and consumed as part of another
build orchestration
step or deployed
to the appropriate resource.
It's fairly modular
and flexible.
Note that we can actually build
and orchestrate deployments
across individual services
or across the environment
holistically.
I'll walk through that in a bit.
So part of how Artifactory
is used on GCP,
we push the images
from the build.
Obviously during
the build step, we
create a Docker image that's
pushed to Artifactory.
It can also be pushed to GCR.
That's Google
Container Repository.
Note that that
GCR implementation
is a really good
choice, because there's
native support within GKE.
In the case we are using
a private repository,
such as we are in this
instance, we need to create
an imagePullSecrets link with a
Secrets config type using that
kubernetes.io/dockerconfigjson.
Next, we update the container
image through the pipeline.
So as I stated, you're
essentially seeing on the right
there an image of the source
config for the infrastructure
configuration, again in
the independent repository.
So actually, we've gone through
now, we've created the image.
It's been tested and
validated and successful.
We update the Docker
image tag in that config.
Finally, we apply the
changes to the cluster.
Just one quick note,
all of these items
are actually automated
through build scripts.
I'll show you a little bit
what that looks like when
I get to the demo section.
But none of this is
actually done by hand.
Now, we actually
have an overview
of this sort of
cohesive, automated test,
publish, and deploy pipeline.
So starting from the top
left, all of our code
is hosted in GitHub, or whatever
repository you might utilize.
It works the same way.
That then, based
on a pull request,
will lead towards a build
on Travis, which then pulls
the code, builds the containers,
any associated artifacts that
are necessary, runs the
test on a test environment,
and publishes those artifacts
to a binary repository,
in this case Artifactory.
Those containers
are then, as you
can see on the
bottom right, they're
labeled with the
appropriate version numbers.
This implementation, we have
a microservices approach.
We have several
different services
that are tagged with all
of the different versions
for the multiple
different services
with their own version
tags, their own environment.
labels, as well as
describing the type of code
that we're utilizing
for that implementation.
Then Travis then makes
a call to deploy this
to the Kubernetes environment,
which pulls the containers
from that repository.
Note also a key thing here is
that monitoring is built in
throughout the entire
process through a number
of different sources.
So we are monitoring,
obviously, via Stackdriver.
We are also getting
notifications from GitHub,
as those pull requests are
being approved and succeeding
or failing, similarly
on the Travis side.
All of those have hooks,
and in our environment
are integrated to notify
us via Slack channel.
All that then creates
our full application.
So you see this is
utilized across all
of our different environments
for web, backend, iOS,
and Android.
And so this is a
representation now of basically
our completed
infrastructure that I talked
about we would be implementing.
So you see it utilizes
those shared services
across the multiple clients,
pointing to a load balancer
to Kubernetes Engine.
In this instance,
we're not technically
going to go into
detail of that here.
But we have two database
types for representing
different types of data.
We also have cloud storage.
And the key factor, again,
here is at the bottom.
We have the representation
of the binary repository
being Artifactory and our
source control being GitHub.
So the continuous
integration dev pipeline.
So this is essentially
how we get our code
through to the integration
steps all the way to deployed
in our dev environment.
I'll walk you through that.
So essentially, we
have our source code.
In this case, I'm going to
follow the source code path
for our front end application.
So our application source
code is in our master branch.
For that to work then
we have a pull request.
That's created.
It's reviewed by our team.
It's approved.
Code is then merged into master
with a new application version.
That new commit triggers
a build on the master
branch in Travis CI.
Then we see Travis
CI making the call
to now successfully
build a new image,
pushing it into Artifactory.
Once that checks out, we
move on to the next stage,
where it checks out the dev
branch in the associated pod
repository.
So in this case,
the pod repository
is that independent
infrastructure repository
we're using separately from
our application source code.
And then it updates a deployment
container in an image.
The changes to the
deployment.yaml configuration
are then committed to the pod
repository in the dev branch.
Then you see down there, we
have the web pod repository.
The dev branch has
then been updated.
And that commit triggers
a new build process--
next step in the build
process, which builds
the dev branch in Travis CI.
That process is actually
the deployment step--
so utilizing a combination
of gcloud and the service
accounts we mentioned earlier,
as well as several different
build scripts that are part
of the setup of that pod.
It successfully deploys
the resource configurations
to the Kubernetes resource.
Once that's done, the image on
the Kubernetes side, the images
will then be pulled
into that deployment.
And rolling updates are made to
the underlying infrastructure.
So the next step is the
continuous integration
for a single or multiple
container promotion.
So this would be if we
want to just update--
again, I'm talking
in this instance
about a microservices-based
environment.
So if we wanted to just
update a single service,
we would follow this step.
So here, you see we had the
backend pod for the dev branch.
In order to promote to
QA in this instance,
a pull request gets open
against the QA branch.
That pull request,
once approved,
then updates a single
or multiple image tags,
depending on the
configuration we're
choosing, in the deployment.yaml
to the versions in dev.
Then it's reviewed and approved.
And then code is merged
into the QA branch.
Once that happens,
that triggers a new
build on Travis
CI, again running
through a similar
process to go through
and actually execute
the build stages
and then deploy to
the cloud environment.
So this gives you sort
of a representation
of how the releases can be
attributed from one environment
to the next.
So we have multiple
different versions
of each service in
dev, UAT, and prod.
We have an overarching version
for the environment level.
That's noted at the bottom.
In this instance, the
front end and backend
are different pods altogether.
These pods have a
series of containers
that describe the pods.
So going from one
environment to the next
involves kicking off
a CI build process
that reaches out to
the deployment.yaml
for that specific
environment and applies it
on the appropriate cluster.
This can be orchestrated with
either different branches
or different folders.
In this particular instance, we
are using the brand segregation
for different environments.
So this is the in-depth
process around how
we do the continuous integration
for environment-to-environment
promotion.
So when we want to take
all of these services
from one environment
to the next,
being promoted from, in
this instance, QA to UAT,
this is that workflow.
So it starts off
with we actually--
so in order for this
workflow to work,
we have a separate
environments repository that
stores the status of each
particular environment,
again using that branch
segregation methodology.
So it has a JSON schema
representing each pod,
as well as the underlying
containers of that pod.
That represents
the current version
of that pod in that environment.
So this environments repository,
we look at the UAT branch,
again similar processes before.
A pull request is
created from QA to UAT.
That pull request
is then approved.
Code is merged into UAT
with the versions from QA.
And then once that
happens, that new commit
triggers a build on the
UAT branch in Travis CI.
Then in Travis, it
checks out the UAT branch
in every pod defined based
on that environment JSON
configuration I mentioned.
Every image in the pod
repository UAT branch
is an updated to
reflect the version that
was mentioned, that JSON config
for the requisite version
of that pod.
The changes to each
pod's deployment.yaml
are then committed to the UAT
branch of that repository.
So it orchestrates
those changes across all
of the different repositories
for each service.
Each of these new
commits trigger a
build in the pod UAT branch in
Travis CI, that then actually,
again, goes through that same
process, builds the container,
makes all the appropriate
configuration change request,
and pushes that
through to Kubernetes.
So next, just to get you a
little bit of a representation
of what this looks
like, I'm going
to switch to this demo
to sort of see basically
what our source
repositories look like.
So as I mentioned, I'll start
with the environment JSON
configuration.
So as I stated, we have
an independent repository
called environments.
Within that, we have
an environment.json
that has the appropriate
configuration
values for each pod
in that environment.
So we have a ton
of different pods
with a ton of
different containers.
Again, we're using this
branch methodology.
So we switch between
dev, prod, qa, and uat.
And those will also have
different configuration values
based on the respective
version that's being
utilized in that environment.
The other point to
represent, as I stated,
we have separate repositories.
So our source code in this
case for the web application
is all hosted in this
single repository.
And then we also have pod
configurations, again,
as represented in the
independent repository.
You'll notice, obviously,
the source code
is where all the devs are
going to do their work.
The pod is, in
this case, managed
and monitored by a headless
user that Travis CI uses.
And as I stated,
that will then update
with the appropriate
image as I represented
in that earlier slide as well
with the correct configuration
value.
Another key point
to be aware of,
as I stated, all of these
tasks that I'm representing
that are happening within
the CI are all scripted out
in our application.
In this case, because we
have so many services,
they all share
similar configurations
in how the CI process works and
how we plan on utilizing it.
We have a common CI repository.
That forms the basis
for all the scripts
that we utilize across
our application.
[MUSIC PLAYING]